- looks good morning are we all today
did I I heard some hellos did Donovan
make you do the hello thing this morning
you know where he says hello and says he
didn't hear you and makes you say hello
louder no no my name is Edward Thompson
I'm a program manager at Microsoft and
today I want to talk about continuous
integration in particular I want to talk
about continuous integration using Azure
pipelines and how we can get some more
advanced and more modern continuous
integration approaches using that real
quick about myself I'm a program manager
on the Azure DevOps team I focus right
now I focus on continuous integration
and continuous delivery so primarily
within you know Azure pipelines
especially enabling open source projects
to bring their builds over and to
validate their that you know pull
requests are good and and that the
health of their open source project is
high before before I did that I was
actually working on git so my
backgrounds in version control before
that so you know primarily within as
your repos and then at github before
before that as well if you're not
familiar with Azure DevOps so I guess if
you missed Donovan's keynote earlier
Azure DevOps is the refinement of a
product that we used to call Visual
Studio Team services before that we
called it team foundation server and the
idea behind Azure DevOps is that it's a
set of developer tools for you to use to
enable your productivity in other words
it's it's a set of tools to help you do
DevOps better and there's no such thing
as a you know enabling a tool if you've
that to let you do DevOps if you just
grabbed as your DevOps you're not gonna
suddenly do DevOps I wish I wish that
were true I wish I could build a tool
that made you successful
with development with operations with
the whole DevOps methodology but I I
can't do that because DevOps is more
than just a tool despite the fact that
we named it as your DevOps we named it
as your DevOps because we want it to
help you with your DevOps but it it is
not DevOps alone because DevOps is
requires three things it's the union of
people process and products to enable
continuous delivery of value so you have
people you have engineers you have ops
and you can have a product like Azure
DevOps to help you on your journey to
DevOps but you also do need these these
processes so I don't want you to think
that that this is going to without
changing your processes bring you to a
more successful DevOps or more
successful continuous integration
strategy right these will help you but
they are not it alone so again we used
to call this team visual studio team
services now it's Azure DevOps and we
split it up into several different
components so we've got Azure boards for
your planning we've got Azure repos for
your version control system and then
we've got Azure pipelines so Azure
pipelines is now a standalone product
that you can use for continuous
integration and continuous delivery and
that was really the reason that we split
these products up into the the azure
DevOps family so that you can use Azure
pipelines for your CI and CD build
systems even if you're not using our
version control so if you're using
github if you are using bitbucket if you
have a gift you know repository server
hidden under your desk please don't do
that please don't store critical
infrastructure under your desk but if
you do that's fine too we can we can
actually build out of that and release
out of that and that was really the goal
and moving to add your DevOps and
splitting these services up was so that
we can allow you to enable it even if
you're not using the rest of the suite
so you can use JIRA for bug tracking
you can use github for for your version
control and then you can still use Azure
pipelines we've made really significant
investments in the CIN CD space over the
last few years and so I'm really excited
about what we have in Azure pipelines so
first of all we have a a modern CI
infrastructure so what that means is we
support using Y Amal if you if you
haven't played with the build
infrastructure in a couple of years you
might remember you know a nice pointy
clicky interface to configure your
builds we still got that if you like the
pointy clicky interface that's great but
we strongly encourage you to go add your
build definitions as gamal the animal is
just a build description language it's a
text file it's actually stands for yet
another markup language because as
engineers were bad at naming things but
the idea behind the animal is that you
can check that file in that describes
your build right next to your code so
you actually check in the way your code
gets built and that's really really
useful because as your code evolves over
time let's say you let's say you're
you're shipping an on-premises you know
a box product right you know you've got
a version 1.0 you ship it on a CD let's
let's pretend it's 1995 for a second
having that build description checked in
as Y Amal allows you to define how
version 1.0 got built and then as you
evolve
version 2.0 as you evolve your code your
build changes to and so you can actually
update that Y Amal and check it in to
reflect the code that you're building at
any point in time so now let's say
somebody comes along and has a bug in
version 1.0 that you need to go fix you
need to hop fix it right so what do you
do you get check out v 1.0 and with y
amal you now still have you get checked
out
the build description for version 1.0 as
well in you know ye oldie days back
before we checked this n we would have a
build server that that now knew how to
build the newest version of the code but
we'd have to try to remember how to make
it build version 1.0 again because
dependencies have changed we'd added new
things we'd added new build scripts and
it was just a big pain you know we at
Microsoft we actually employed people
their full-time job was to remember and
configure how to build various versions
of the products you want to build a
version of Visual Studio 2015 there is
one person who remembers how to do it he
is handsomely paid because his job is
not easy but hopefully we can get that
information out of his head once a guy
named Lauren learns a great guy I want
to take that information out of his head
and put it in yeah Mille instead so that
not one person remembers how to do it
the builds themselves describe how
things work so let's actually take a
look at what this in fact looks like all
right so this is a sure DevOps so right
now I have a project here it's a really
really simple project it's a web app
that says hello world there it is it's
in fact the simplest web app well
actually that's not true it's actually a
little bit complex let's let's come into
the code
this is Azure repos so this is our this
is my code in a git repository and what
I actually have is a dotnet core
application with Razer pages it's all
very very fancy
it's way overly complex I think the only
way that I could have made a hello world
more complex was by using Java let's
let's pop over here there we go and if I
actually look at the code what I've got
is a docker file there
and so what this does is it takes the
dotnet core docker image and uses that
as a base and builds my application on
top of it so if I docker build that I
get a container and I can docker run
that there we go
and here in my local repository I've
made some changes right
if I if I pop back over here and look at
what's in production right now not real
pretty I know a little bit of HTML a
little bit of CSS not very much but I
can improve upon this and there we go
it's a little prettier it's at least not
black on white and it says hello to
y'all so that's nice so how do I
actually get this into production well
let's build a build pipeline for it
that's there we go build a build
pipeline for it so again if I go back to
Azure repos to my code the first thing
that you see here in the top corner is
setup build so as your DevOps is
actually trying to lead me through best
practices so that I can so that I can
actually set up a modern sort of CI NCD
system from my code so let's go ahead
and click that and the first thing it
wants me to do is configure my pipeline
so what it's gonna do is it's actually
gonna look at my code and try to figure
out what I'm building to try to give me
some some steps through and right up at
the top is asp.net so it's it's actually
analyzed my repository and decided I'm
building an asp.net project which I am
but
what I sow and let me go ahead and click
on this just just to illustrate this so
this will create some yeah Mille so this
will basically set up some best
practices for a dotnet asp.net build
using Yambol and so I can just click
save and run and it'll go ahead and
build this run my tests all that stuff
and that's that's very handy but what I
actually want is to do a docker based
build so I've got that docker file what
I actually want to do is build and
deploy with containers and so that's
something that we've actually added sort
of recently is the ability to identify
docker files as well and walk you
through an experience that is a docker
based build and then a deployment of
that container and so what I actually
want to do is enable some preview
features if you're an azure dev ops user
so we ship every three weeks we ship new
features every three weeks and often we
hide them we hide them up there in
preview features and so we can turn them
on first of all for our for ourselves
from Microsoft we just flip a future
flag on for ourselves so that we can
test it we turn it on for MVPs next and
then we open it up to you so we can go
into preview features and the one I want
to enable is called multi stage
pipelines now that is a really kind of
dull name that doesn't really get across
what it's doing it's actually the entire
new see the next iteration the next step
of our continuous integration build and
deployment experience so it takes the
animal to the next level so we started
with visual designer which was all just
pointy clicky which is fine you know
it's very easy to setup the next step
was Yambol which allows me to do that
configuration as code that I was talking
about lets me check in my yeah mold that
describes my build - my repository but
it's not super accessible right yeah
milles not easy to write like look at
this you know you would have to go and
actually you know read a bunch of Doc's
to figure out what it is this is the
next step where we're actually combining
those two ideas so we're doing
configuration is code with Hamel but
we're actually bringing in the visual
designer on top of that so we're gonna
have you can either if you just want to
write yeah no that's fine but if you
want a simpler experience where you
don't have to read a bunch of Doc's
we've got a designer on top of that
which will emit yellow so you get the
best of both worlds is the goal and so
here's that and so part of this new CI
this next iteration is that it
understands docker containers so it's
going to lead me through a docker build
and a deployment with that container and
when I click on that instead of just
getting a screen full of Y amyl that I
have to edit over here on the right-hand
side
it's asking me questions so this is the
first step of that wizard experience is
walking me through the setup so what I
can do here is basically select an azure
container registry that I want to
publish my docker container to so it's
gonna run my build inside the docker
image inside docker rather and then it's
going to deploy it to Azure container
registry I'll select my subscription
click continue select my container
registry there we go it knows the docker
file and then it's gonna actually
scaffold up a Yambol for me that's
customized for my repository and for a
deployment even into Azure container
registry now of course you don't have to
deploy to as your container registry you
could deploy to docker hub you could
deploy wherever you want there we go so
that looks good to me
I can scroll through and check this
stuff out but fundamentally here's what
it's done it's actually set up a service
principle for Azure container registry
so it's taken care of all of the hard
bits for me I can click save and run
there we go and that will go ahead and
do the build if we click on that we can
actually see exactly what it's doing
it's going through the steps checking
out my git repository running my build
within docker and then it's going to
publish that to the container registry I
actually like watching this stuff but
I'm not gonna sit here quietly and make
you watch it in case you don't
so let's come back to that in a minute
in the meantime what we did here was we
came through Asscher pipelines we set up
a git repository that was in Azure repos
so no surprise that as your pipelines is
good at building as your dev ops
projects let's say I'm in Shinto earlier
though that we could build code from
anywhere whether that's github or
bitbucket let's take a look at that
there we go
[Music]
let's pop over here there we go so here
I've got a github project it is in fact
the exact same project but this time I
want to build out of this github
repository instead of out of add your
repos the absolute easiest way to get
started with this if you are in github
is to use the new Asscher pipelines
extension it's in the marketplace in
github so I just need to click on
marketplace search for as your pipelines
and I can set up a plan and the thing
that I'm happiest about is that this is
free if you're using github and you are
building proprietary applications close
source applications it's free you get a
limited number of minutes per month you
get one parallel pipeline you can grow
into that but the the there is a free
plan if you are an open source project
however it is completely free so you get
unlimited build minutes per month for
your open source project you get 10 free
parallel pipelines to build that so you
can validate pull requests you can you
can do CI builds for your open source
project all very very free so all I have
to do is click a few buttons and if
you're not actually an azure dev ops
user already what this will do is let
you set up a new azure dev ops account
there we go
I'm gonna sign it with my Microsoft
account you could actually in fact just
sign in with github this is something we
launched a little bit ago right after we
acquired github a lot of people said oh
are we gonna have Microsoft accounts to
sign into github actually no nobody
actually likes using Microsoft accounts
to sign in instead we went the other way
so now you can sign in to Azure DevOps
with your github account a little bit
easier so I'm gonna go ahead and sign in
and of course I have two factor
authentication enabled which is always
fun for demo don't you know don't don't
look at that there we go
and so now what it will ask me to do is
either choose an existing Azure DevOps
account which is fine
I've actually got a bunch or I can
create a new Azure DevOps organization
it'll ask me where I want to put it West
Europe great if if you're here I'm here
right now but let me let me select
central u.s. because that's where I'm
usually at in fact and then go ahead and
click continue and so this will actually
set up an all new a sure DevOps account
for your builds out of github again
completely free if you are using open
source and completely free if you're
doing proprietary projects with a
limited number of minutes as well and
then it'll just walk me through the
exact same setup that it did before I
can select my repository it will suggest
a template for me again the current
iteration will give me an at asp.net I
could also opt into the new just like I
did before and go through the docker
image I'm gonna click save and run there
we go and it's gonna kick off a build
out of my github repository so super
straightforward to get started out of
github
of course this could also be bitbucket
it could be a get server under your desk
it could be subversion so there's
nothing tying you to the rest of the
azured DevOps family just because you're
using Azure pipelines okay so while
that's building let's pop back over here
and see if our build completed in fact
it did so this has actually published a
new image to Azure container registry
there we go we can scroll down and see
that it went ahead and did all of that
that is delightful and now what I want
to do is actually update my site in
production so I can go back to the azure
portal and update that to point to that
new docker image that just got pushed if
you're not if you haven't used the azure
container registry it is just I think
delightful so here's my container
registry
and hello world let's zoom in ah ha
there we go
so I've got a bunch of new containers
and I can update this image right here
point it to that new container that just
got deployed
and that will go ahead and let's go
ahead and restart that as well now of
course in a the next step here would be
to actually set up continuous delivery
so that I actually had a release step
that did this for me I will take a look
at that in a second woops I actually
selected the wrong container it turns
out I've done this demo a few times my
bad I knew it was rough when I just had
a bunch of numbers to pick and forgot
which one was which so but that is that
is basically the way to get started with
a a docker based build cool so I set up
this this build out of github over here
one of the biggest advantages to me with
using builds out of github is again the
the open source nature of it because
again we give unlimited build minutes
for open source projects with ten free
parallel pipelines and I maintain a
bunch of open source projects like I
said I came up through version control
so I do some work on various get open
source projects look at to look at C
sharp those sorts of things and for me
as an open-source maintainer one of the
most important things about the health
of my project is having a CI CD system
that I can trust so every time somebody
sends a pull request I want to be able
to validate the code that they're
sending so I want to build it I want to
run all my tests against it and I want
to run regular CI builds against my
master branch to ensure that it is still
healthy and I want to do this on as many
platforms as I support so it's very
important to me as a maintainer to make
sure that
to make sure that this all works so here
is another one of my open-source
projects
it is a calculator app it is like my
hello world app it is also ridiculously
over-engineered it's actually a front
end with REST API so it actually has
REST API is to do simple arithmetic so
if you ever need to know what 1+1 is you
can call my REST API it's very handy it
is right here and this is not dock rised
this is actually just a very
straightforward nodejs app so let me go
ahead and npm start that for you so at
least so you can see it and that's on
3000 there we go
it's just like the you know pocket
calculator you had when you were young
if you are as old as I am which okay so
none of you remember this but I do like
retrocomputing so yeah so I can say 4
plus 4 equals and it gives me 8 back
it's kind of what you expect out of the
calculator and again this is a
JavaScript front-end talking to a npm
back-end over rest api's so what i
actually want to do now is go back to
this project over here on github and i
want to make sure that pull requests
coming into my open-source project are
vetted that there that they run the
build and run my unit tests because i do
actually have unit tests for this to
make sure that you know when you do 1+1
you get to it seems simple but this is
programming we're talking about let's
not make any assumptions ok so what I
want to do is go back to my Azure dev
ops account and I want to create a new
project I'm going to call it calculator
and it's going to be a public project
that way people who are coming into my
open-source project can actually see the
builds - I don't want private builds for
an open source project
click create and when that finishes what
I'm going to do is go to pipelines and
create a pipeline so I've already
configured this with github so it's
already set up so it's it's nice and
authenticated so I can just select
github here and it will show me my list
of repositories that I have I'm gonna
click on calculator I'm going to give it
access to that particular repository
because you can give as your pipelines
access to repositories on a repo by repo
basis just get all those web hooks set
up there we go and again it's going to
take a look at what's in my repository
and try to figure out the best thing for
me up at the top it decided I'm a
node.js app which I absolutely am so I'm
gonna click on that scroll through if
you are a node developer you'll you'll
recognize this if you're not npm install
is kind of like a it's a package restore
it's similar to new get restore or you
know whatever I depend on other packages
so I need to do that NPM install step
which will get my dependencies and then
npm run build which it's JavaScript so
it's basically a no op if this were
typescript though it would do a you know
a transpile step or something I want to
add one more step here and that's NPM
run tests cuz I actually do have unit
tests because I'm a you know a
responsible open-source maintainer and
then I'm gonna click save and run and
what that'll do is it will check a yamo
file into my repository directly on
github and it'll start my build so if I
go back to github and hit reload I
should see that yellow file that it's
it's building there we go
so again
it gets checked right into my repository
that's configuration is code that helps
me manage my build alongside the actual
code that it's building okay and if I
pop over here again what it's going to
do is it's going to do that check out
stuff it's going to install my
dependencies and then it's going to run
my tests so let me actually zoom in on
here and we can scroll down and these
are actually my tests there we go
so that's great it's exactly what I want
the other thing that it's done is that
it's gone ahead and added to github some
web hooks so now anytime anybody opens a
pull request against my project it will
run this build any time I merge
something into the master branch it will
run this build as well so let me let me
create a pull request let me go back to
my code let me browse through here let's
assume for a minute that I am an
open-source contributor I found this
project I've decided I what I really
need in life is a REST API to do simple
arithmetic and I'm checking it out come
through here I don't know how many of
you are open-source maintainer x' like i
am sometimes people drop in and they
they have interesting requests or
interesting pull requests for you
because when people jump into a new
project you know it's hard to get the
entire scope of it at once and so if you
if you come in here and you are perhaps
not super familiar with javascript which
i gotta tell you i'm actually kind of
not cuz this looks weird to me I've got
this add function and what it does is
you know if you look at the subtract
function that makes sense it it returns
a minus B if you look at the
multiplication function it returns a
times B you get the idea
but the add function looks weird it
doesn't return a plus B it returns plus
a plus plus B and that seems really odd
so in fact let's let's maybe make up
pull requests where we change that so
let's edit this file we can edit it
right here in github and get rid of the
plus a plus plus B and just make it a
plus B that looks much nicer right that
looks like math now and we scroll down
and we're going to create a new pull
request there we go
and scroll down and create the pull
great and now what'll happen is if we
come down here this is the area that the
github shows its checks and the first
thing it does and you can see that right
now we've got the green check mark is it
make sure that there are no conflicts in
the code in other words that you know
you can actually perform a merge if you
click complete pull requests that the
code can actually flow through you don't
need to go fix up any conflicts the
second thing it's going to do is turn
yellow and what happens is that it has
asked as your pipelines to do a
continuous integration build to validate
that this pull request is good that it
builds and that our tests pass and in
fact it does not our tests do not pass
and we can go get more information if we
click on the checks area and then go to
Azure pipelines directly there we go and
now we can click on that job click on
the red area and scroll down and see in
fact that things did not work right if I
look here at my errors well so what I've
done is I was I have a test that adds
two positive integers in fact it adds
twenty one and twenty one and expects
the answer to be 42 in fact the answer
was not 42 it was to one to one
yeah that's that's weird
types are hard in JavaScript it turns
out and so what we've actually done is
string concatenation with those two
numbers the plus a coerces a into an
integer so that it can actually be added
to another number as a number instead of
as a string with concatenation so it
turns out this pull request is totally
bogus even though it looks good right
plus a plus plus B doesn't seem to make
any sense at least not to me who's not
expert in JavaScript and type coercion
so I might have been inclined to merge
this
and there are a lot of pull requests
that you get as an open-source
maintainer that look good but might have
some subtleties especially when you
start thinking about cross-platform if
you're building on Mac Linux and Windows
if you're building on iOS and Android
suddenly things get a lot more subtle
and it makes a lot of sense to validate
every single pull request and this is
true whether you're an open-source
project or just building something
within your organization within your
enterprise within your startup okay so
very very helpful to always always use
continuous integration builds and pull
request validation builds cool so one
thing that I didn't mention here right
we built a dotnet core app we built it
in docker it it makes sense that that as
your pipelines would do a good job
supporting Don that core right the.net
team is like literally the building next
door to us so I think they would you
know sneak over and hurt us
if we didn't do a good job let's on that
course so we try really hard there right
no surprise
this is an NPM app and in fact it's an
NPM app building and running in Linux so
one of the things that as your pipelines
provides is a number of cloud hosted
build agents for you to use and again
that's totally free if you're an open
source project and it's free for a
limited number of minutes if you are if
you are not if you're a closed source
project but we maintain all these build
agents for you so you don't have to
think about it so in in the cloud and
Azure data centers we have a bunch of
Windows machines ready to run your build
we have a bunch of Linux machines ready
to run your builds we in fact even have
a bunch of Mac's
ready to run your build and so again
it's it's very helpful
or what kind of application you're
building to be able to to do CI so here
here's an example of that here I have an
iOS project so this is a really simple
game that I created let's take a look at
it let me open up Xcode there we go and
what this is is a you know just a real
simple concentration style game with you
know emojis and what I want to do is
make sure that I can actually hey I
found a match look at that what I want
to do is is make sure that this builds
and that my tests pass and in fact I
have a test like this one that will make
sure that the game is in fact winnable
right so it will basically solve the
puzzle and make sure that at the end
that you win so I don't have any idea
how to do that better than just brute
forcing it so if you've ever seen
wargames this will look familiar but the
idea here is that I want to make sure
that that this also stays healthy and
thankfully Azure pipelines has a bunch
of Mac's ready to go ready to do this
build as well so I don't mean I'm not
limited to Net Applications I'm not
limited to Windows I can build on iOS
apps on a Mac so let me go ahead and get
that set up let's pop back - there we go
so let me go ahead and set up a pipeline
here here we go again
I'm gonna select out of github
and I'm gonna select my repository and
once again it's gonna take a look at
what's inside as soon as I actually you
know allow it to there we go so it's
going to take a look at what's inside
and try to identify a Yemma file that
will best build this project so in this
case it's an iOS app it is going to
there we go
suggest Xcode so if I look at my Amal
the first thing I notice is that now I'm
building on Mac OS so that's that's
really cool and then it's super
straightforward to to do an Xcode build
I want to change this just a little bit
instead of doing a build I've got a
bunch of unit tests so I want to run the
test action whoops I want to run the
test action instead of the build action
for my scheme I want to give it my unit
test project name and I want to actually
run this instead of just doing a build I
want a full unit test experience so I
want to run on an iPhone simulator so we
can actually run iPhone simulations in
the cloud
I'll do it debug build and I'm gonna add
one thing because I have multi target so
I'm gonna say destination platform
option and I happen to know this I know
this yeah Mille so you can understand
perhaps why we're we're adding the
visual designer back because this is not
super obvious and I'm gonna say publish
j-unit results but the one thing that
does help is that this is actually the
Monaco text editor so this is the same
text editor here that is in the S code
so if your vs code user this might this
auto-completion suggestion might look
familiar
so we've actually added our gamal
description to the vs code and two here
so you do actually get some help again
you know not as much as the as bringing
the visual designer back so I'm gonna
click save and run
and what this is going to do now is it's
gonna queue up a job and it's going to
go in provision a Mac so again we've got
a bunch of Mac's just hanging out
waiting for your builds it's a mix of
Mac minis and Mac Pro's the old trashcan
ones you know that are this big if
you've ever built a datacenter you might
think that this much space for a single
computer is not super optimal and you'd
be right that's why we do it so that you
don't have to in a previous life I
racked a bunch of Mac's I would
encourage you to never have to do that
yourself so what it's going to do is
it's going to get that git repository
and it's going to start that build and
again just like my other project it's
actually set up all of the pull request
validation builds and continuous
integration builds inside my repository
so that I can always stay healthy there
we go
it's running now it's running Xcode so
if I actually go in here I can actually
see it running my tests it's actually
going to run the the same tests as over
here where it cycles through every
single tile looking for that match just
to make sure that the game is winnable
and that ensures that anybody who opens
a pull request will never break the
actual fundamental winning of the game
so it's doing that right momentarily so
you can see it's running the test double
tap it's running the test select
matching tiles then it's running the
test
tap on visible tile is ignored tests
eventually it will get to the winning
test right
in the meantime let's look at let's look
at another project so this is an open
source project again that I'm the
maintainer of it's called Lib get to the
idea behind Lib get to is it is a sea
library for git repository management
and then on top of that people add in
various we call them bindings so if you
don't want to write C because who the
hell wants to write C in the year 2019
you can instead add c-sharp on top of
this so there's a layer that just does P
invokes down to Lib get to so that you
don't have to and that gives you a nice
c-sharp library for a git repository
management that's called Libby to sharp
there's a ruby one called rugged there's
a node get that is no js' and Lib get to
short sorry Libby - is used by a number
of gooeys that do get work it's used by
github it's used by bitbucket it's used
by as your repos so basically anybody
doing it at some point interacts with
this library right when you click merge
pull request on github it uses this to
do it so it's kind of important that we
don't screw that up and the way that we
do that is by having a pretty
conservative attitude but be a ton of
unit tests and see a ton of CI builds on
top of that for all of the platforms we
support because on Azure repos that's we
actually run a cluster of Windows
servers to do this work github runs a
cluster of Linux machines and so we need
to make sure that we don't break either
of those scenarios so that's pretty
straightforward when it comes to Azure
pipe lines right we've seen we've seen
Mac builds we've seen Linux builds we've
seen Windows builds but it gets a little
trickier for Libya too because again
we're just a library that anybody can
use and so if you happen to want to
write a git applique
for your phone which yes does exist it's
probably more useful on an iPad I got to
think but hey I don't have one of those
there's an app called working copy and
it uses Lib get two to do all that work
and that's really cool but this is an
arm device and what as your pipelines
doesn't have is a bunch of our machines
hanging out ready to do your builds but
what it does do is give you a real
virtual machine to do your builds in it
doesn't you know run inside a docker
image where you don't have access to the
actual hardware you get a real virtual
machine for every build and so you can
do things like virtualization and so if
we take a look in here in our bill
description what we do is we build
within a docker image and we run this
step I'm not sure how many of you have
ever seen this in a docker image what it
does is it enables QEMU mode QEMU is a
really popular emulator that can target
a bunch of other architectures so by
running this docker command now I can
run what are called multi arc docker
images so I can run arm images I can run
PowerPC images and so I can actually
incorporate other architectures as part
of my continuous integration builds even
architectures that Azure pipeline's
doesn't have native build machines for
so I can just run this all in QEMU and
so what I actually end up seeing is that
our build our code texture list starts
out really straightforward
we've got an D 64 for Linux on a bunch
of you know with a bunch of different
compilers i've got mac OS i've got some
windows AMD 64 windows x86 both with
visual studio and with mingw and then
things start getting a little more
interesting down here I've got Linux x86
builds we only have amd64 Linux boxes
and in fact it's a little bit tricky to
get x86 running on them at the moment so
we virtualize this so we've actually got
x86 docker images that run through QEMU
but the more important part for our
friends that are building high phone
apps at least is this arm 32 and arm 64
bills so if I look at that what I
actually do is again I I do that
register qemu step and if you zoom in
here it sets up all of these QEMU
targets arm SPARC PowerPC M 68k s/390
so if you want to build IBM mainframe
applications with Azure pipelines you
can and then it goes ahead and runs that
build within a docker image so we
basically just have a docker image that
is arm 64 with all of our dependencies
installed and we build within that so
you're not limited to just the platforms
that we give you just Mac OS just Linux
just Windows and in fact I mentioned
earlier that I kind of like retro
computing
so I'm working on some projects and of
course I want a CI pipeline for them and
those projects happen to be around the
Commodore 64 if again if you're as old
as I am this may look familiar if not
well this was one of the early
microcomputers certainly the first one I
had in my house and I think that the
first one that many people ever
interacted with very affordable very
useful tons of fun and what this is this
is a Commodore 64 emulator called vice
and somebody has done terrible things
device what they've done is they've
taken it because it's much a C and
they've run it through a web assembly
compiler and out pops a bunch of really
disgusting job
a script like megabytes of really
disgusting JavaScript but that means I
have a Commodore 64 in my browser this
actually works right let me hit reload
there we go
blinking cursor right this is of course
that was the first program everybody
wrote this is the second the infinite
loop of hello worlds and so that's fun
right this is obviously just a gimmick
but but my goal here is to not make this
a gimmick to actually make this a useful
build pipeline for my project so let's
look at what I've done again I've gone a
little crazy with the over-engineering
so this web app is not just vice running
in webassembly in a browser there's
actually a dotnet core application here
and what it actually does is yes it does
deliver that web assembly but if we look
at my razor page what you'll actually
see is it looks for a program right so
what this is is this is a Commodore 64
image of an actual application if it
exists it will get served up if it
doesn't you just get the standard old
Commodore 64 exactly as you turned it on
for those of you who never experienced
this when you flip the switch on your
c64 it comes up and says this and at
this point you would load something off
your tape yeah
sweep drives or something off of a disk
drive which even that seemed sounds
archaic at this point and so what I want
to do is actually be able to run the c64
code that I actually create and so
that's what does this so all I have to
do is take my code compile it into
something name it file dot PRG in this
web app and
it will get delivered up and so that is
here so here I have some c64 assembly if
you have never written any assembly let
alone c64 assembly don't worry about it
again this is a simple hello world app
in assembly and let's change our hello
instead of saying hello world let's say
hello and DC cool let me just go ahead
and check these changes in that's
practice of course would be to open a
pull request but let me see if I can
shrink this down a little bit I guess
not
right so now if I go back just updated
that code and now let's create a build
so what I'm actually doing is creating a
docker build very similar to what we did
before with our other hello world
application oh whoops
and of course I forgot it actually
queued one github did when I actually
merged that change forgot all about that
wasn't thinking but let's take a look at
the what it's actually doing here so I'm
building off of my other docker image
sorry
I'm building a docker image rather and
publishing it up to Azure container
registry just like the other one did
I'm also reconfiguring my web
application so I am actually doing a
continuous deployment step here as well
our hello world app we just did the
build and publish to container registry
now we're taking it a step further
telling our web app to run the new
container so that's how we get
continuous deployment out of here and
let's take a look while that's building
real quick just at the docker image
Acme Acme is the name of a c64
cross-compiler so it will take our
assembly spit out hello dot PRG and then
it will basically take that cloud 64
that's that dotnet core app with the web
assembly and it will lay down if you're
not familiar with docker files what
it'll do is it'll take the output of the
the cross-compile and put it in as
program dot PRG and that is the file
that our web app is looking for which
will get served up so is that done it is
done great so now if we go here and hit
reload what we should see while it
downloads those megabytes of web
assembly over conference Wi-Fi megabytes
of webassembly somebody's session just
got out everybody's checking their email
right now so what we should see is that
it actually bootstraps that webassembly
finds the program on disk and actually
there we go
finds that program on disk and runs it
so let me zoom in just a little bit and
in fact we got hello in DC so no kidding
I am actually using this I really am
playing around with c64 in my spare time
my copious spare time you have a lot of
spare time as a as a Microsoft employee
it turns out and so and so I am you know
check my Twitter you'll you'll see that
the the crazy project that I am
embarking on and I wish I could take
credit for this this I love this a guy
named Tony Landy came up with the idea
of using acne as a cross compiler and
using Vice in an emulator or rather
using Vice in web assembly for a c64
build and release pipeline so again it
is we talked about at Microsoft at least
on my team we talk
about running any build on any platform
DevOps for really absolutely any any
system again whether that's Mac Linux
Windows or iOS devices or something
truly crazy like a c64 or an IBM
mainframe so if you have any questions
we're just we're really just about out
of time so what I will do is I will
actually stick around I'll stick around
here I'm happy to answer any questions
if you are shy or if you are in a hurry
and don't want to hang out and wait the
best way to reach me is twitter i'm e
Thompson that's Thompson without a P and
I'm happy to answer any questions you
have about Azure pipelines as your
DevOps continuous integration and
continuous delivery especially for your
open source projects but really for
whatever you're trying to build if you
want more information you can check us
out on the Internet or again just hit me
up on Twitter so thank you so much
please enjoy the rest of your NDC
[Applause]